million questions for you but I got to
start with the first one with the the
one that I uh uh my first one which is
uh how surprised were you when Akiva
said oh yeah I'm working on the I Am
Legend sequel
I'll surprise yeah I was super surprised
and very curious I was almost jumping on
the phone and saying can I please be in
can I please be in can I please be in
I'm a huge Ikea fan I think he's such a
wonderful writer and he basically was
the first writer that I got to see the
word closed apart from you know like
coming to the US it was my first
American film
that I was very excited to to hear that
they were continuing
with with the movie I hope they do I
don't know what where they are with it
but I hope they do I would imagine if it
does get made that you will get a phone
call uh
it's such a it was such a joy to work
with them and also like it's interesting
because it was 20
three when I did the film like it's been
such a long time ago and I did so much
work afterward I I think it grew as an
actress as a woman and as everything so
it would be nice to revisit that
material that team to reunite with Akiva
who is a screenwriter that I deeply
admire yeah do you know him uh I do but
not like friends but yeah
um he knows what he's doing he's gonna
land on his feet yeah he's amazing yeah
I I but I do think it's going to take
the real time you know like the 20 years
to help with the story anyway I would be
shocked if you don't get a phone call so
jumping into why I get to talk to you
one of the things about this movie that
really impressed me was how Robert
edited it it is so fast moving but it
never feels fast it's just like it's a
really well edited film and it obviously
keeps you on your toes all the time what
was it like reading the script for the
first time and then seeing the finished
film because obviously you know it's
going to be different yeah it was it was
interesting because was the first time
that we I was understanding what kind of
genre style and filmmaking he wanted to
do with this this film but the main
question was reading a script like this
you always can imagine it's like reading
a book you imagine a world you imagine
those twists and turns and that kind of
roller coaster survive that the script
had already but you put that on its toes
to to bring it to life
I knew it was going to be a challenge
and that's why I was so curious to to
jump on board whatever Robert invited me
to do I would say yes I've always wanted
to work with him I did work with him on
a different project but he was a
producer for Predators but I've never
worked with him as a director
so I knew that he was going to pull off
like
in any ways because he
comes from this type of filmmaking he
comes from independent filmmaking he
comes from just grab your camera just go
and just do it and it's it was exciting
to have him on set already thinking how
he was going to edit because he edits
his films and he also dp's his films
that he this one he's the co-dp like him
and and Pablo another DP so it was
interesting how he directs the scene and
sets the scene already thinking how he's
gonna edit so I do think that helped for
a film like this for a story like this
that there's so much going on and
there's so much twist and turn
that he already had a vision on how to
film already editing his mind just a
million things but one of what is it
like reading a script like this for the
first time though because I mean I've
kept on guessing but I can't imagine
reading it where you don't you know what
I mean what was it like I think it was
exactly what you said is basically like
wait what and then oh oh and I hope
people feel that uh when they see the
film because reading the scripture felt
like a lot was going on it was
interesting as a read it was interesting
as it was different that everything that
I was reading at the time but also like
when you read the script with the direct
that is like Robert attached already you
kind of like read the script thinking of
how he's gonna make that and and it was
interesting to
to read with that Vision like to kind of
like be oh
and a bunch of things I didn't expect
that he kept on coming so I really hope
the audience goes through the same
Journey to the same Arc of being like
wait what like that changed or this or
that I really hope it's hard to talk
about the film without giving spoilers
for example yeah it's one of those but
uh believe me yeah uh what is a scene
that you got on the first take that you
didn't think you were gonna get on the
first take and what's a scene that you
thought would be easy or what what's the
scene you thought would be easy uh but
ended up taking like all day I think it
seemed that it was easy that it took Uh
I that can I say that not the last scene
but like one of the last scenes that we
are coming to a house and Robert really
love a house but he didn't love how the
other side of the house looked to do
shot and you know shot this way in one
shot this way so we had to shoot
everything this way then do a company
move to a different location to then
shoot the other side of the scene which
sounds very very easy but once you're
talking about a production a company
move from a location to a different
location to shoot the other side it took
way longer than what I read and descript
expected it was challenging as an actor
to keep that emotion and and create that
world and environment
what it was faster it was the motorcycle
which I thought it was going to be take
much longer and it was much faster
because we were at Troublemaker studio
so it looked like it was a longer track
but it wasn't we were just like going in
circles and the way that he filmed it
kind of cheats of where we were and all
that but also it's his mind so there's a
lot of things that happens yeah yeah the
thing about I've been to Troublemaker
Studios and it's pretty crazy his
backdrop because I was watching the
movie I'm like oh yeah I recognize that
from Elita you know like it's he he it
really working with him has to be like
gorilla filmmaking 100 like he's like
that he has that on his DNA and he's
very much passionate to
filmmaking but the Simplicity of it he
doesn't want to overthink about it he
just wants to keep on doing and that's I
think it's it's a way of doing it's a
it's a choice and it's his DNA so once
you're in it you just need to go along
with it and and he wanted it to seem
like Elita he didn't wanted to hide that
it was okay for him to show that so I
thought it was interesting yeah I mean
again it also saves a ton of money
reusing sets you know yes and especially
after covid because the film got really
hit by covet and as soon as covet ended
or almost ended for everybody
that challenge of how to keep financing
a film how to it was very uncertain I
think now we're getting off of it of
okay now it's back to normal but a lot
of films were affected by by covert and
ours was for sure yeah also most people
aren't going to recognize that it's his
Backlot you know the average person is
going to be like oh they built that you
know all of us we know so much about
Troublemaker that it feels like almost
an homage to Troublemaker that film how
much do you throw a breaker in it he
does it on every film uh listen I'm a
big fan of Brit Marling and I believe
that I love her yeah and I believe you
shot a retreat
um uh what can you tease about that
project if you're a big fan of her you
like the OA you could say I do yeah yeah
it's she's
wonderful actress but a brilliant writer
as well a really really brilliant writer
and the scripts were just phenomenal her
and Sal butman glitch to the brilliant
work on the script it's a very classic
whodunit story but in a beautiful
interesting environment with really
wonderful actress like a theater group
and I think it's going to be a wonderful
mini-series and and Brett is not only
acting and writing but she's also
directing and it was a joy I'm I look up
to her a lot and it was just a joy to to
get the chance to work with her yeah
yeah I can't wait an honor
I I honestly can't wait to see it my
last thing for you uh what are you
actually going to film this year do you
know I just finished a a show for apple
called dark matter but that's going to
come out only next year so I'm still
waiting to hear uh when but it's a near
to come and
um I'm gonna can you hear this
you hear my cat
no you have a cat yes
I thought that's what you heard
technology but um I just finished that's
gonna come probably next spring I think
and now I'm supporting the writer strike
I don't know what's coming up next I
have some scripts I have developing some
projects in Brazil I have a production
company there I'm producing some stuff
and and reading and writing I have a
podcast that I'm gonna do there as well
but for now I'm supporting the writer
strike and trying to see what's going to
happen next and that don't need to stop
uh and uh maybe I'll see you at ccxp uh
later this year